[Music]
hey you guys
it's tuesday
sorry tom what's the matter oh nothing
people in the comments section um
saying this looks like a discount aliens
this movie
it's not though it has nothing to do
with that and it's nothing really like
that
i mean it does have some elements of
alien in it but
yeah yeah it's kind of like it kind of
reminded me more of um event horizon
yeah kind of sort of
about this uh colony ship i think it's
called the elysium isn't it yeah or were
they going to elysium no that was the
name of the ship yeah they were going to
tanis though
that's right
it's this giant ship
and
it's got like little ring worlds around
it where you know it can spin so you can
have gravity and
they're on this
130 year journey to tattus
and uh it's got [ __ ] tens of
thousands of people to think that the
ship's the size of a city
and um
well make a long story short one of the
crew members wakes up and there's some
kind of disaster going on the ship
they're in there they're in hyper sleep
there's some kind of disaster going on
and he wakes up by himself and when and
he had some something was wrong with his
hyper sleep he couldn't remember he
couldn't remember very much
so then he wakes up his uh
next in command like his commander
and the commander remembers a little bit
more and he puts him on this mission to
try to get the ship restarted and fix
the ship
but something's all wrong that
there's dead bodies on the ship there's
damn things that look like monsters um
they start running into other survivors
some of them have been awake for a long
time
you know six seven months
and they're being hunted down by these
uh humanoid creatures that are on the
ship that are kind of tribal
and uh
turns out there
there's kind of like this weird religion
going on i don't know how much i should
talk about it to to uh to spoil it
because a lot of people have seen this
movie it's a real good movie
um
it's it's it's unique i don't remember
any other kind of movie like this per se
like it has elements of a lot of movies
like i said it kind of reminded me
there's a little bit of alien a little
bit of event horizon the monsters in it
sort of looked like the monsters from
the descent like the cave crawlers yeah
um and there's kind of some [ __ ] going
on there but there's
i don't know it has elements of a lot of
different ones but i thought it did
something interesting with them you know
what i'm saying it's weird because this
came out in 2009
and
it's a british
german
film
and i feel like
when it came out it kind of got [ __ ] on
and nobody went to see it and it didn't
i think it cost like 33 million to make
and it only made 20 million back yeah so
they were actually thinking about doing
a sequel or doing an extended universe
but they never did it because the movie
wasn't successful and i think even the
production company that did it like went
bankrupt
and uh so for whatever reason it just
you know critics didn't like it
audiences didn't like it and it just
kind of went into limbo but then over
the past few years
it's really seemed to like develop a big
cult following because now if you kind
of go look like i saw a bunch of lists
of like you know best sci-fi from the
past 20 years or whatever this is
usually on there and like a lot of
people talking about how underrated it
is and i don't really don't know
why it didn't do better back in 2009
there's nothing to do with timing yeah i
guess it was just maybe the timing yeah
maybe people thought that it was too
much like
another movie or i don't really know
what the problem was because there's
absolutely nothing wrong with this movie
this is actually like a pretty solid uh
sci-fi flick it had like a lot of really
cool ideas in it
it's kind of like that movie that had
that
that that the one was underwater it was
called underwater wouldn't it yeah yeah
um there's nothing wrong with that movie
that was a great movie just the timing
was wrong they put it out there wasn't
many the studios really weren't behind
it
but that that was a good movie now
people are starting to uh appreciate
that one wasn't perfect but it was a
good movie
yeah i kind of feel like maybe the same
and this might have suffered from the
same thing that maybe underwater
initially suffered for is that everybody
thinks oh it's going to be just like
alien right so it's like let's not
bother and i'm just kind of like well
well everything's been done okay pretty
much uh so
all you can do is really kind of put a
different twist on it or just make it
entertaining in its own right you don't
have to be completely original because
nothing is
so
i kind of feel like that's what
underwater suffered from everybody's
like oh it's like alien but under the
ocean actually no and it wasn't they
were saying it's like the abyss
yeah yeah that's what the one i get it's
like blue like the abyss and
[ __ ] matt
a little [ __ ] mad not not not
not not not the good man the bad man you
know
not the good man yeah he's like oh yeah
he goes oh that oh okay so like uh
he he's a dude that just shits on
everything and i said that's good movie
underwater he goes yeah oh that one it's
kind of like the abyss right and i was
like no it was but it's water it's
underneath the water
dude saying this like it was jaws
[Laughter]
that's like saying star wars is the same
as battle star galactica is the same as
star trek it's the same as flash gordon
because they all said this in space
right
and he's like yeah
the [ __ ] out of here
you know the guy dudes that are like
that you know well some people a lot of
people are like that some people just
can't enjoy anything right and so want
everybody else and i think too that
there's like a certain type of person
and it's usually dudes that think that
that makes them seem cooler or smarter
an expert
but matt can't get laid that they yeah
that they know more than you because
it's like oh wasn't that just like that
yeah
you know what i mean it's just and i
can't stand people like that yeah i
can't uh mango says is it on a streaming
channel it's actually on tubey for free
right now yeah i think it's on amazon
prime but you might have to pay like a
couple bucks to watch it but you can
watch it for free on tv i think it might
have been maybe because there weren't
any real big american studios behind it
because you said it was a foreign flick
yeah that's probably what pro that's
probably why yeah it's like uh
constantine films i think like picked it
up so they probably sabotaged and i mean
it does have american uh people like you
know dennis quaid is in it and norman
reedus is in it
for like two minutes right
um and they got uh some
good-looking chick in there she's been
in other movies i i reckon
you probably recognize her from man of
steel man of steel that's right i
recognized her too but i didn't see man
of steel so i recognized her from dark
the german uh netflix series which is
amazing by the way if you guys haven't
seen it it's three seconds yeah to add
to the chaos uh people that have been
people who are in this colony ship are
from all over the world
so they're being kind of revived at a
hyper speech
sleep at random times
uh
and they don't always speak the same
language like one of the guys in here is
the kind of like this badass vietnamese
dude he's kind of like a tribal guy he's
real good with head-handed weapons but
he can't understand what anybody's
saying
yeah he's in it for a long time
um
yeah the german girl i guess she's
german she is german yeah that's a
german actor she can speak english um
and then the two other crewmen speak
english
but they just run into people that have
[ __ ] degenerated into cannibals uh
all kinds of weird [ __ ] happening on the
ship
and you don't really know why and that's
kind of the reveal and if i don't want
to really spoil them yeah don't spoil
the ending because the twist because the
ending is good yeah the ending's really
good you're like oh okay that's what
happened oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah and you know
i'll i'll give you a hint right now the
journey was only planned to be 128 years
and
it wasn't 128 years that's not how long
they were out there
okay so you just got to see the movie
it's pretty good well this i guess the
idea for this like the guy that wrote
the original screenplay whose name is uh
travis malloy
he wrote this original screenplay back
in the 90s like back in the late 1990s
and his original idea was
that the
ship was called the pandorum and that it
was a prison ship they were taking
all of these prisoners from earth that
were too dangerous to stay on earth and
they were taken to a prison place it was
kind of like alien 3 i guess sort of
um so he was kind of kicking that around
for a while and then it got bought and
like greenlit and i think like paul w s
anderson uh who's you know produced and
directed a bunch of movies he kind of
got behind it and then they brought in
this director and i can't remember uh
the director's name christian christian
oliver
and he said hey i have a
sci-fi script that's kind of like this
except in mine it's this crew that wakes
up from hypersleep and they have amnesia
and they can't remember what their
mission is
so he says to the screenwriter do you
want to just combine those two ideas
yeah so that's what they did um so the
ship which was originally called
pandorum in the original story they
changed the name of the ship to the
elysium and made it not a prison ship
but like a an ark essentially uh you
know that was going to another
earth-like planet to re-pop to populate
it and then they took i mean they took
out the whole prisoner aspect although
they left some stuff in there but
um so that's kind of where the idea came
from is just those two ideas and then
they made pandorum
the name of
this uh
kind of like a psychosis
that happens if you're in space too long
or in hypersleep too long or something
like that
and it factors into the plot like quite
a bit like especially toward the end
which i kind of feel like that part like
toward the end was reminding me it's not
i you know i want to say it reminds me
of event horizon but it's not i mean
event horizon that was kind of like they
were in the ship and it was like hell
you know what i mean kind of um this
isn't like that but
the psychosis angle reminded me a little
bit yeah
he explained it it's kind of like
being in and out of hypersleep for too
long or too many times and then a bunch
of traumatic experiences can cause you
some kind of damage in your brain
yeah and uh
you have a difficulty
telling reality from
hallucination and paranoia
spray damage basically yeah and
they're waking up
and
they know they've been in hyper sleep
for a long time because they can't
remember much of anything they remember
some things but not a lot
um like yeah like some don't remember
exactly what the mission was
they go this was something special they
you know they'd find in the
name of the ship yeah they didn't know
the exact mission and then it starts
coming back to them
the longer they're awake the more they
remember because really what they're
supposed to do they explain this too but
there's like several crews
and
they're only and their shifts and i
think their shifts are two years yeah
they're awake for two years and then
another crew relieves them and then the
other ship goes so so nobody's supposed
to be in hyper sleep longer than a
couple of years i guess at a time yeah
there's always supposed to be somebody
awake watching the ship
but some time in the past this system is
broken down
and they don't know that it's it's they
have to do basically an investigation
and that's kind of what's happening the
main problem is is that the reactor on
the ship is getting ready to shut down
uh shut down or blow up i don't remember
exactly i think it's shut down right
yeah because it keeps going in and out
so they keep like losing power and they
can't like access a lot of the function
of the ship they can't get into the
bridge they can't really see what's
going on where they are where they are
right so they don't even know where they
are yeah you know they gotta get to the
death so this one guy is trying to get
to the reactor to [ __ ] reboot the
reactor
he's not sure he remembers how to do it
yeah because he's an engineer that was
like his job but he's you know he's been
in hyper sleep and he's kind of like you
know a little adult yeah uh and
disoriented so
he's kind of like well i hope i can
figure it out like when i get there you
know he runs into other people and tell
them i'll forget it man you'll you'll
never make it it's too dangerous there's
a lot of bad [ __ ] going on in that
direction you know down that end of the
ship and
there's other people that are just
giving up hope and they don't know how
crazy they are some of them are pretty
[ __ ] crazy they just decide they're
going to eat each other
yeah and you can't figure out like where
these monsters came from because you're
led to assume that these were not on the
ship to start with yeah they don't know
what they are so they don't know where
they are where they came from but
they've evidently been there for a long
time
yeah there's whole piles of eating
bodies
yeah that's another thing just skeletons
and [ __ ] and they find like the ship is
kind of like booby trapped yeah and so
like people because i guess the ship had
it had all those rotating crews however
many people that was and then i think
that there were
colonists who were all in hypersleep so
i think there were 60 000 of those like
in these big like hypersleep chambers so
there's a [ __ ] ton of people on the ship
and i guess these monsters are going
through and like cracking open the hyper
sleep chambers and like eating them is
that what they were doing because they
are eating the people looks like there
was fighting and stuff going on because
some of the chambers were empty so i'm
assuming that the monsters went in there
or when the people were were awake they
would like catch them in traps because
they had like kind of booby traps all
over the ship i guess yeah so you had to
like kind of avoid that so there were
wars that happened in there yeah the
ship's not a fragile
modern type spaceship it's something
that hasn't been made yet this [ __ ] is
built to last it's like a city
or a huge oil tanker it's got [ __ ]
pipes and sewers in it and um
big conduits and huge
huge open rooms filled with damn
shipping containers cargo containers
like you see it they had a port
and all that shit's [ __ ] splayed
around everywhere
uh some of the stuff looks like huge
steel columns and
you know the ship's built to last it's
you know not a weak ship
so it it's taking a lot of damage inter
internally
it's like
it's like a city
yeah and they're trying to fix the city
infrastructure basically
and you don't can't see out of it it's
just solid
uh so you know it's not like you're
having micro meteorites coming in
through the windows or anything it's not
fragile
so but it's a good story
and this is one and this is kind of
interesting because while we were
watching it i was thinking to myself you
know how how we pissed and moaned about
uh alien versus predator uh requiem and
how [ __ ] dark it was you couldn't
tell what's going on now this movie is
dark too and quickly edited but you can
always tell what's going on so i said
well see now that's how you do it right
i mean it's not so dark that it's like
murky i kind of feel like that was the
problem with the aliens made pretty well
the quality is good i would probably put
it on par with like
a really good star trek movie
like you know one ones with riker and
those guys like that
but yeah i mean it's way darker and it's
like way yeah i mean i really really
liked a lot of the [ __ ] about this and
honestly i liked dennis quaid's
character whose name is peyton right and
he's in the uh you know he's kind of
like telling the
the younger guy bauer like where to go
you know because he's like this is how
you get to the reactor
so he's like running him through the
control room so he doesn't like get run
around the ship or anything like that
but he gets to like kind of
he's he's suffering from uh from some
[ __ ] too because he's also been woken up
yeah like in a [ __ ] way and he can't
remember anything and so and then
they're trying to remember like what
happened to earth like you know where is
my family because our families are
supposed to be on here with us because
this is like a they're supposed to go
tannis is this earth like planet and
they're supposed to go and colonize it
so they have everything on this ship
like to colonize they haven't been to it
they saw some photographs from a probe
and uh it they saw some plants like a
little flower look like a little white
tulip inside rock type
crevice and [ __ ]
and uh but based on the readings all
this this and it should be like a lush
[ __ ]
garden of eden
and uh you know
you find out everything you find out
what happened with the ship you find out
what happened with tennis you found out
what happened to earth
you find out um
the mission and how long they've been in
there
find out where the [ __ ] monsters came
from but you gotta kind of wait to the
end and
it kind of under it's in that last 20 or
30 minutes it all starts unfold and
it'll
give you a picture of what it happened
it all makes sense
yeah because
it'll up to then like i said it's kind
of like a mystery and it's it's like a
mystery and like a just adventure
because you know the the guy bauer
uh teams up with you know the german
lady and the uh vietnamese dude and
they're trying to get to the reactor to
like restart it and they only have like
a limited amount of time yeah and then
they're being chased by these monsters
and they can't figure out you know
wherever the [ __ ] they came from or
what's going on with it and so it's kind
of like an adventure but then like
toward the end it gets more into
explaining everything and
gets more into kind of maybe
i don't want to like the psychosis angle
you know the pandora mangle the maybe
unreliable narrator angle it gets into
that too um but like i said i want to
spoil too much of it it's just really
interesting and like this this is always
interesting to me when this happens that
like i said when this came out i mean it
got terrible reviews
um i didn't deserve terrible which yeah
which i thought was very strange because
i'm like well just you know probably the
worst thing you could level out oh it's
derivative i'm like yeah all sci-fi is
derivative it's like you know
everything's been done and honestly it
took as i said it took aspects of a lot
of different things and kind of melded
them into something different and i was
just like i don't see anything wrong
with that and i don't really i can't
really see any other criticism that you
could level at it other than that um so
i don't know it just i guess it was just
the timing and then audiences didn't
really dig it either because you know it
was they were spoiled back then this was
released now it would have been a hit
probably it probably would yeah
there were a lot of good movies being
released around that time
people were kind of taking them for
granted compared to a lot of the
[ __ ] that comes out now this is
[ __ ] this is a good movie it's
there's not it is a traditional flick
there's nothing real super artistic
about it it's kind of
like i said it is a little bit
derivative i mean it you can
it's it's a very traditional
storytelling in terms of there's a
beginning a middle and an end and then
there's some reveals and stuff it's you
know
there isn't any kind of like uh
there's some twists but the twist makes
sense there isn't any
crazy [ __ ] in it
um
it's not even so much twists i would
more call it like reveal reveals what
happens yeah right not really twists
it's more like a reveal of like what's
actually happening
and it's just a standard good sci-fi
adventure slash horror movie there's uh
horror elements to it yeah dead bodies
uh mangled [ __ ] [ __ ] some gross stuff
uh combat
uh combat with [ __ ] monsters kind of
martial arts [ __ ]
looking type yeah that guy that plays i
can't remember that actor's name but
he's like a mixed martial artist so he's
been like in a bunch of other movies um
[ __ ] ray gun type stuff you know
futuristic weapons uh
it's just
nice production design too i gotta say
like the inside of the ship looks really
cool i thought i just thought it was
kind of like on par in terms of quality
as say like
a star trek movie from those days like
you know with [ __ ] kirk and with
riker and picard you know what was the
it's a little darker because you know
the ship's [ __ ] ruined and doesn't
have power
but in terms of production quality kind
of like one of the star trek movies
which you know wasn't
top top notch but good enough you know
maybe not as nice as rather khan i mean
that's that's [ __ ] real nice looking
to this day yeah um
actually star trek the motion picture
still looks badass to to this day
looks just more like uh was it star trek
insurrection or maybe like event horizon
like that
but it looks yeah the look of it to me
it's not quite as
um over the top as event horizon because
i feel like that had a little bit more
like artistic or like nightmarish
uh you know kind of geekeresque looking
stuff whereas this looks yeah this looks
more like
less artistic and more like realistic
yeah but still it looks pretty cool yeah
kyle said uh yeah this is an excellent
watch
yeah i mean i really liked it uh
somebody also brought up leviathan which
is also pretty great and leviathan's a
lot older though yeah this one looks a
lot better than yeah that was 90s wasn't
it i think i saw that in the theater
this looks a lot better than it might
have been really nice but uh
and and a lot more
leviathan had some crazy [ __ ] in it this
one's a lot more sane
anyway leviathan yeah i mean this one's
pretty grounded like i said it does it
can play with some things like some more
kind of nightmarish [ __ ] toward the end
when they get into like the whole
pandorum like psychosis type thing but
other than that like i said it's not
over the top like event horizon which is
kind of just more like a nightmare but
it's you know it's a lot more grounded
in reality there are these alien
monsters but uh
you find out how that happened
so yeah and and again it's very
believable
like how that happened
uh kyle also says yeah this one and
sunshine from 2007 are both high brow
sci-fi i really liked sunshine from 2007
you would probably really dig that i
somebody loaned it to me like a year or
two after it came out
and i remember really really liking it
and it's i was thinking about it the
other day i think i was thinking about
we were watching that movie last night
and i said oh we should probably watch
that one because you'd probably really
like that too
but because this i don't know i guess
this one's kind of similar to that i
think this one
this one sunshine and event horizon i
think that would be a good like triple
feature and then they put it in and
there's another one that kind of reminds
me of this from around this same era
it's another one that punches way above
its weight it's hard to find
hunter prey yeah that's right hunter
prey was real well made real well
written
about some imperial like start like kind
of like stormtrooper type
guys
hunting down this fugitive alien out in
this desert
and um it's actually kind of like the
unofficial sequel
to enemy mine yeah that movie and it was
made for almost nothing i mean like for
a very very low budget and it's they did
a really good job yeah the dudes that
made it were from hollywood special
effects guys they had some cool costumes
because we could make movies with this
they went out and made a movie and it's
[ __ ] really good
and check that one out hunter pray i
can't believe we haven't reviewed that
one we need to review it because we've
seen it a couple times we'll review it
and i don't think it's available on
blu-ray i think it's only available on
dvd
yeah and it even
it referenced the guys who made it
made it an unofficial sequel to enemy
mind they they actually refer to the
drax which that was from the
yeah that's right that was how that was
the the hint that they dropped because
that wasn't trademarked it wasn't
copyrighted so they talked about the
drax the drax were the aliens from enemy
mine maybe we should do that for a
matinee next week do like a double
feature of enemy mine and hunter prey
if we if we can get a hold of it we're
gonna do them separate okay we'll do
them both but we'll do them separate we
can do them like the same week again
yeah doing the same week because i
haven't seen enemy mine for like forever
that was a good thing i kind of feel
like um
god who just i feel like uh
what are their [ __ ] names
that uh that channel that does review
they just did enemy mine like a couple
weeks ago yeah and uh
enemy mine was a good sci-fi movie
because it was based on acting
yeah that was a real good one well it's
you know we've said this a million times
you don't need a gigantic budget if you
have a good story and characters you
give a [ __ ] about that's really all you
need and good alien character and just
having people that like care about what
they're doing you know whatever it is
they're doing whether it's special
effects yeah in my mind see that one
first it's about two dudes they're both
fighter pilots but one's a human and
another one's an alien called a drac
they're at war
and they're both crash landed on a down
planet together it's kind of like a
robinson caruso where you have two
castaways trying to survive on this
planet and they start off as enemies
they hate each other but they need each
other to survive real good movie enemy
mine yeah i always liked him yeah no
need for me too said he just showed it
to uh his son which what enemy mine yeah
did he like it
yeah i don't know yeah that's i can't
remember like how old are you now watch
now watch hunter pray if you can find it
yeah
it might be easy to get like now but i
feel like it's on you can get pretty
much everything now i didn't find it now
i looked a couple years back i wanted to
get it on blu-ray it didn't exist
only dvd and um well it's probably on
streaming because it was somewhere i
would imagine
you might be able to even watch it for
free i should check
i'll write that down because i can check
like on a streaming service and maybe
because
you'd be amazed like if he likes enemy
mind he would like a hunter prey is
better
i think it's actually he said oh yeah he
dug it yeah yeah okay she was worried
he'd be bored but no shum hunter pray
he'll like that one even better
a lot more action in it
similar
but yeah so
seriously um
again i don't understand like why this
movie just
you know flopped when it came out in
2009 timing just timing i guess um i bet
you american studios [ __ ] sabotaged
it
yeah i don't know i mean they released
it here they released it in the uk so it
did get a theatrical release but it just
didn't seem to go anywhere and like i
said i don't really reading some of the
reviews i'm just like did you guys just
watch the same movie i watched because i
don't know
i don't know why they why it got so
savage some people just watch it they
don't really pay attention to
they don't really they don't really
immerse themselves in the stories i i'm
gonna [ __ ] start chiding these young
these young children they don't know how
to watch the movie they don't know how
to watch a movie
you can't watch them you can't watch a
movie well i know what they're looking
at we kind of talked about this before
thank you very much no need for me to
outlander 2008 is good okay we'll have
to check that out
um
i've kind of said this before and
specifically when i'm talking about
horror movies i this is why i don't
really like people that go to see horror
movies and they're like that wasn't
scary yeah and i'm just kind of like
well did you like watch it do you like
allow yourself to get into the movie
yeah i think a lot of people don't and i
think a lot of people don't it's almost
kind of like they want to be cooler than
it or something and it's like why bother
going to see it then i want a horror
movie to scare me that's the point of it
so it's like i'm gonna allow myself to
get involved with the story unless it
sucks i mean i'm not gonna just you know
but even if it kind of sucks usually
i'll watch it to the it has to be pretty
bad or pretty boring before i turn it
off i'm willing to give most things a
chance you know what i mean but because
it might get better you don't know how
it's going to resolve itself i like to
watch the whole thing before i
you know have any judgment on it
you know but i i know i know that i'm
different in that regard i guess i don't
i don't know i just i really like movies
i really like horror movies and i just
feel like if you're gonna watch it
then you know pay attention to it unless
you're just kind of like watching it
just for shits and giggles and just for
drinks and you don't really need to pay
attention that's a different kind of
movie but
i mean if you're gonna watch something
like this then this movie i will say you
you do actually have to pay attention
because otherwise i don't think you're
gonna well maybe you'll still know
what's going on but it's it's better to
like
pay attention all the conversations and
all the little flashback scenes and
stuff like that because it's
i think you might get a little lost if
you're not paying attention maybe
did you think that what's that i was
reading the comments would you say i
said do you think that um
if you weren't
100 paying attention to this movie you
might get a little bit lost yeah i do
kind of feel like you have to pay
attention you got to pay attention to
the movie it's not one of those ones
where you have to like take notes or
anything like that but you do have to
like be cognizant of what everybody's
saying if you're just on it for a ride
you're not going to get what they say a
lot of times yeah
you have to pay attention to what
they're saying yeah so that's why i mean
that's why i always put like closed
captioning on too because one i'm deaf
and two it helps i don't want track of
the stuff yeah and i yeah i don't wanna
um but yeah it's not just so much that
that i can't hear very well so it's like
oh it's always good to have that on but
it really is because you know i might
like miss a word or i might think that
this character talks but so i like that
it tells you like which character talked
so i know who's
talking and it's like so i know like
what's going on it's it makes things
much much easier
uh what's tomorrow's show about jenny
tomorrow we are doing a show about
cursed objects okay because remember i
said when we did the urban legend show
and i said oh i had a couple stories
about like cursed paintings and i kind
of wanted to get into those and then i
was like well maybe we can just do a
whole cursed objects show
so i put that in the patreon poll and it
won overwhelmingly so we're gonna do
cursed paintings i'm gonna do the hope
diamond uh cursed
dolls probably won't do like robert or
annabelle too much because i think we
talked about those on some other shows
but i got like a cursed wedding dress i
got all kind of fun [ __ ]
so we're gonna do uh that should be that
should be a fun show that should be a
function but uh yeah that's what show
tomorrow night is about
uh so are we done do you have anything
else you would like to add okay
so thank you everybody for dropping by
and uh we will see you guys again
tomorrow evening at 5 p.m for our
regular episode
so have a good rest your day and we'll
see you guys tomorrow